D
BY HIS COMMUNITY AND HAS EVEN
SUFFERED TWO STROKES.
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR HIS
HARROWING STORY TONIGHT, BUT
FIRST, KAMALA CAN'T AND WON'T.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
TODAY, VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS
TRAVELED TO TEXAS TO CHECK THE
BORDER BOX AND PLAY A GAME OF
MAKE-BELIEVE.
>> IT IS IMPORTANT TO BE CLEAR,
WORKING TO BUILD A FAIR AND
FUNCTIONAL -- WE FEEL VERY
STRONGLY ABOUT THAT AND I DO
KNOW WE INHERITED A TOUGH
SITUATION AND IN FIVE MONTHS WE
HAVE MADE PROGRESS BUT THERE IS
STILL MUCH MORE WORK TO BE DONE
BUT WE'VE MADE PROGRESS.
>> Laura: PROGRESS?
LIES AND MORE LIES.
NUMBER ONE, SHE AND BIDEN WERE
NOT HANDED A TOUGH SITUATION AT
THE BORDER.
THEY CREATED A DISASTER AT THE
BORDER, THEY DID.
THANKS TO TRUMP'S REMAIN IN
MEXICO POLICY AND AGGRESSIVE
INTERIOR ENFORCEMENT, ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION CROSSINGS WERE
DRIVEN WAY DOWN UNDER TRUMP AND
NUMBER TWO, BY PROGRESS SHE
MEANS TOTAL ABDICATION BECAUSE
MOST AMERICANS DEFINE PROGRESS
AT THE BORDER AS A REDUCTION IN
THE NUMBER OF ILLEGAL CROSSERS.
BUT FOR BIDEN AND HARRIS, I
GUESS PROGRESS MEANS AN INCREASE
IN CROSSING REGARDLESS OF THE
HARM AND COST TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
I LIKE TO CALL THIS OPEN BORDERS
COLLUSION AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF OUR GOVERNMENT.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
COMMITTING AN ONGOING CRIME
AGAINST OUR BASIC SOVEREIGNTY, A
CONSPIRACY TO UNDERMINE THE RULE
OF LAW AND THEIR REFUSAL TO DO
WHAT WORKS TO STEM THE FLOW OF
HUMANITY AND TO AMERICA.
THIS FISCAL YEAR ALONE, BORDER
PATROL HAS INTERCEPTED NEARLY A
MILLION MIGRANT CROSSERS AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW MANY OF
THEM HAVE BEEN RELEASED INTO THE
INTERIOR PART OF THE COUNTRY,
BUT YOU KNOW THAT NUMBER HAS TO
BE STAGGERING.
IF HARRIS WERE A SERIOUS PERSON
WHO ACTUALLY PUT AMERICA'S
INTERESTS FIRST SHE WOULD HAVE
TRAVELED WHERE THE ACTION IS IN
THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY BUT OF
COURSE, THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN TOO
EMBARRASSING AND REVEALING
BECAUSE THEY ARE, THE BORDER
ARRESTS STAND AT A WHOPPING
271,000 AND COUNTING THIS
FISCAL YEAR SO OF COURSE
KAMALA HARRIS DECIDED TO SKIP
THAT REGION AND INSTEAD, VISIT
EL PASO, WHICH HAS 2.5 TIMES
FEWER BORDER ARRESTS AND FOR
GOOD MEASURE, A DEMOCRAT MAYOR.
EVERYTHING I SAW TODAY WAS
BORDER THEATER FROM BEGINNING TO
END.
THERE IS NOTHING SERIOUS ABOUT
ENFORCEMENT AND SHE WAS ALWAYS
IN SEARCH OF MYTHIC ROOT CAUSES.
>> THE WORK THAT WE HAVE TO DO
IS THE WORK OF ADDRESSING THE
CAUSE, THE ROOT CAUSES.
I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL THAT WE HAVE TALKED TO
THESE LEADERS AND SECRETARIES,
THE FOCUS THAT WE HAVE PLACED ON
THE ROOT CAUSES.
HE CAN'T REACT TO A PROBLEM
WITHOUT SOLVING IT AT ITS ROOT.
>> Laura: EVERYONE KNOWS THAT
ROOT CAUSES IS JUST WASHINGTON'S
WAY OF SAYING WE HAVE NO
INTENTION OF SOLVING THE
PROBLEM.
AND DESPITE THE GRAVITY OF ALL
OF THIS, HERE IS WAS ONLY FOR
ABOUT SIX HOURS IN TEXAS AND
MUCH OF THAT TIME WAS SPENT --
AT THE ILLEGAL CROSSING HOT SPOT
KNOWN AS THE EL PASO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT.
OF COURSE, THE VEEP SPUN A
TOTALLY FICTIONAL VERSION OF
EVENTS TODAY.
>> WHY WAS RIGHT NOW A GREAT
TIME TO MAKE YOUR FIRST TRIP TO
THE BORDER?
>> IT'S NOT MY FIRST TRIP, I'VE
BEEN TO THE BORDER MANY TIMES.
I SAID IN MARCH I WAS GOING TO
COME TO THE BOARD AS THIS IS NOT
A NEW PLAN.
>> Laura: IF HER -- WEREN'T SO
INFURIATING IT WOULD BE
ABSOLUTELY HILARIOUS BECAUSE
WITH SO MUCH TIME HAVING PASSED,
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S BORDER IS
KIND OF A SIDESHOW AT THIS
POINT.
IT'S A DISTRACTION FROM THE REAL
STORY BECAUSE WHILE SHE
EMBARRASSES HERSELF IN EL PASO,
THE BIDEN DHS IS MOVING FULL
STEAM AHEAD ON DISMANTLING OUR
BORDER PROTECTIONS AND
IMMIGRATION SYSTEMS.
JUST DAYS AGO, THEY NOTIFIED
CONGRESS THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
RELEASE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
ILLEGALS INTO THE INTERIOR OF
THE COUNTRY WHO WERE PREVIOUSLY
DENIED ENTRY UNDER THE REMAIN IN
MEXICO PROGRAMS.
THEY ARE GOING TO PLUCK THEM OUT
OF MEXICO, BRING THEM BACK AND
RELEASE THEM.
ISN'T THAT NICE?
THAT'S NOT ALL, JUST TODAY BY
THE STEAM IS FURIOUSLY TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO RESCIND A
TRUMP ERA POLICY THAT ALLOWS FOR
THE IMMEDIATE REJECTION OF
ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSERS DUE TO
COVID BECAUSE THEY CARE SO MUCH
ABOUT COVID.
THIS OUTRAGE ALIGNS PERFECTLY
WITH SOMETHING HARRIS SAID TODAY
ABOUT WHAT OUR OBLIGATIONS ARE
AS A COUNTRY.
>> WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY AND
IF WE IGNORE THAT RESPONSIBILITY
IT WILL VISIT ITSELF UPON US IN
A VERY DOMESTIC WAY.
>> Laura: SHE WAS TALKING
ABOUT THE REGION,
CENTRAL AMERICA AND MEXICO, SO
APPARENTLY OUR RESPONSIBILITY IS
TO OTHER COUNTRIES.
THUS IT NOT ONLY WILL THE MIDDLE
CLASS AND ALL AMERICANS FRANKLY
BE HIT WITH A HIGHER COST OF
LIVING BECAUSE OF INFLATION NOW
BUT YOU CAN ALSO EXPECT WAGES TO
STAGNATE AS WELL, ALL BECAUSE
BIDEN BOWED TO THE BUSINESS BODY
ON THE FAR LEFT AND THEY ARE
FINE WITH HAVING A GLUT OF
WORKERS BECAUSE A GLUT OF
WORKERS IN THE UNITED STATES
KEEPS A WAGES FLAT.
CERTAINLY KEEPS THEM FROM
RISING.
SO ONCE AGAIN WE SEE THE UGLY
TRUTH ABOUT TODAY'S DEMOCRATS.
ALTHOUGH KAMALA HARRIS WAS PUT
IN CHARGE OF THE BORDER ISSUE,
SHE NOT ONLY CAN'T DO IT BECAUSE
SHE IS IN WAY OVER HER HEAD, SHE
WON'T DO IT BECAUSE SHUTTING
DOWN ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSERS
MEANS PUTTING AMERICA FIRST AND
WHY SHOULD THEY EVER WANT TO PUT
A SYSTEMATICALLY RACIST COUNTRY
FIRST?
THAT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
THEY DON'T THINK IT'S THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO TRY TO LIFT
YOUR STANDARD OF LIVING OR
ENSURE YOUR SCHOOLS ARE
FUNCTIONAL OR TO MAKE SURE YOUR
STREETS ARE SAFE BECAUSE IF THEY
DID, THEY WOULD DO WHATEVER IT
TOOK TO SECURE THAT SOUTHERN
BORDER AND INSTEAD THEIR GOAL IS
TO FUNDAMENTALLY TRANSFORM OUR
NATION AND ITS CULTURES SO THOSE
BORDERS, YOU BET, KEEP THEM WIDE
OPEN.
THEY ARE ONLY GOING TO CARE
ABOUT THE BORDER, ABOUT
ENFORCEMENT, WHEN THEY SEE THAT
THEIR ACTIONS ARE IN THIS CASE,
AN ACTION, IT'S REALLY COSTING
VOTES.
AND VERY SOON IT WIL